10 Weirdest Movie Merchandise Ever Made
It’s no secret that the world of movie merch
is a lucrative one for Hollywood, offering
fans items or toys to take them right back
to their favorite movies.
But some products on the market are a little
more questionable than others.
Keep these in mind the next time the next
time you need gift inspiration for the movie
buff in your life.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Weirdest Movie
Merchandise Ever Made.
R2D2 Aquarium
Star Wars is a merchandise juggernaut, spanning
the saga’s nearly 40 year legacy.
But when New York-based retailer Hammacher
Schlemmer got involved, fans weren’t sure
about their contribution to the merchandise
canon.
Known for supplying an eclectic array of gadgetry,
the company prides itself on its weirdness.
For only $79.95, collectors could own the
R2D2 Aquarium, which has since been removed
from their catalogue.
The droid housed an almost two-gallon tank,
and included a built-in periscope for a different
angle on the aquatic action.
With all the color-changing lights, themed
backdrops, and voice-activated sound effects,
the aesthetic of this aquarium was designed
with humans in mind, not fish – which kind
of defeats the purpose.
James Bond Candles
The suits, booze, and cars all add to the
glamorous persona of James Bond, but one product
goes a step further.
In an attempt to capitalize on all aspects
of 007, clothing and lifestyle brand TOCCA
created the James Bond Candle.
For only $38, buyers can make their homes
smell just like Bond’s!
Inspired by his signature car and drink, the
candle’s marketed as having “rich, leathery
smell” reflective of Bond’s environment.
Some fans may question just what the product
has to do with the star spy, but considering
how bankable the character has become, it’s
not surprising.
Harry Potter Vibrating Nimbus 2000
Toy manufacturer Mattel made quite a fuss
when they released a replica Nimbus 2000 from
the Harry Potter franchise.
Excited fans flocked to buy them, eager to
practice for Quidditch tryouts themselves.
Marketed as a kids toy, the battery-operated
broomstick had a vibration feature, which
normally wouldn’t be a big deal.
But because of the nature and placement of
the broom, parents thought it was a little
too adult.
The Nimbus was pulled from the shelves and
has since been replaced with a different,
non-vibrating model made by another manufacturer.
The original brooms are still flying around
on eBay, but because of their rarity, they
can cost upwards of $100.
Assembled The Avengers Cologne Set
Marvel’s Avengers are known for many things,
but how they smell isn’t one of them - until
NOW.
The makers of The Avengers Cologne Set want
you to smell like your favorite superhero,
with fragrances inspired by Thor, Captain
America, Iron Man, and the Hulk sold individually
or as a set.
The idea comes from Jads International, who
released a similar line for Star Trek, but
this version makes even less sense.
It seems counter-intuitive to intentionally
smell like the inside of a sweaty suit of
Iron Man armor, but according to the reviews,
Tony Stark’s scent is the fan favorite.
We can’t say we’re surprised.
The “Dark Vador” Burger
Almost every fast food chain has paired up
with Hollywood marketing at some point, from
commercials to toys, and everything in between.
When a french chain named Quick was promoting
the release of Star Wars Episode I: The Phantom
Menace 3D, they didn’t bother with toys,
and just got creative with the food itself.
When Star Wars-themed burgers hit the menu,
diners were shocked to see that one of them
came on a black burger bun.
The “Dark Vador” burger was a double-pattied
behemoth, leaving customers split on almost
every aspect.
But the loudest critics questioned the logic
of a burger dedicated to a character who technically
isn’t even seen in the movie being promoted.
The Matrix Reloaded Cell Phone
The Matrix showed audiences a darker side
of technology, but an impressively advanced
one, all the same.
It comes as no surprise that the theme continued
with the marketing plans for The Matrix Reloaded.
The movie characters preferred to use Samsung’s
SPH-n270, and replicas were released in a
limited number to the public in 2003.
But it didn’t stop with the snap-sliding
phone: they came pre-loaded with Matrix propaganda,
making it a Matrix-lover’s dream from the
ringtones to the menu design.
Considering how fast the phones themselves
became dated and obsolete, you’d think they’d
be affordable by now.
But they’re not for the budget-conscious
shopper, and can run up to $2,500 on eBay.
A high price to pay considering it only displays
8 lines of text.
Rocky Action Figures: The Meat, Wheelchair
Rocky
Sealed action figures can be a high-value
collectors item, especially if they’re part
of a limited release.
Toy company Jakks Pacific has released many
Rocky knickknacks, but two of them stand out
for all the wrong reasons.
The Meat figurine is an homage to the infamous
meat locker scene from the original film,
with Rocky II getting a post-fight figure
of Rocky in a wheelchair.
It even comes complete with bruises for extra
authenticity!
There’s a lot to love about Rocky Balboa,
but his merchandise isn’t one of them.
300 Leather Briefs
Zack Snyder’s graphic novel action film
300 chronicles the topless battle at Thermopylae
between the Spartans and Persians, and singlehandedly
motivated thousands of people to start hitting
the gym like never before.
And, naturally, licensed replicas of Spartan
leather briefs hit the market to capitalize
on the trend.
Ranging from $79 to $95, it seems a small
price to pay to make a movie fan feel like
one of the chiseled soldiers – even if they
don’t look like one.
Spartan briefs can be bought, but the matching
washboard abs can only be earned.
C3PO Tape Dispenser
As we’ve mentioned earlier, Star Wars has
some of the weirdest themed merchandise on
the market.
Modifying everyday items like toasters, beds,
and guitars in the brand’s image has proven
a no-brainer, but finally, the old “boring
tape dispenser” problem has been solved
by Sigma, the group responsible for the ceramic
C3PO tape dispenser.
If its mere existence isn't crazy enough,
consider that one in mint condition sold for
$200 on eBay in 2014.
Some fans have commented on the dispenser’s
awkward facial features, while others ask
the more important question: why is the roll
of tape coming from between C3PO’s legs?
another person.
Letters to E.T
Ever since its release in 1982, E.T. has been
widely beloved by audiences.
Too bad the same can’t be said about it’s
merchandise.
The 1983 book “Letters to E.T.” is exactly
what it sounds like: a series of letters written
to the friendly extraterrestrial.
Penned by people from all walks of life, the
letters praise both the alien and director
Steven Spielberg, with a few explaining how
badly the senders hope to meet E.T. someday.
The book was probably intended to capture
the nostalgia among fans, but was critically
panned as nothing more than a published case
of ego-stroking on Spielberg’s part.
Hey Screen Ranters!
This is Kati from TheRichest!
If you enjoyed this video, I invite you all
to check out our video on our channel!
Click the link on your screen.
Don’t forget to thumbs up and to subscribe
to Screen Rant!
Thanks!